[Music]
the zelda series has come
a long way since its inception in terms
of combat
we went from stabbing to stabbing while
jumping and crouching
to swinging and performing sword dashes
or spin attacks to full-on 3d swordplay
with lots of different options in just a
span of a decade which
is quite impressive after the release of
ocarina of time however these leaps in
combat innovation
started to plateau and since then the
combat system hasn't seen
too many big overhauls well with the
exception of one particular game but we
will cover that one in a separate
section
on the one hand this isn't really a bad
thing it's inevitable that after
experimenting with different styles and
trying out different things you
ultimately land on something that is
most efficient and start making less
radical changes to the system but it's
not so much about nintendo adding to the
combat than it is about them
taking things away on the surface level
breath the wild's combat system seems
radically different because of the many
new additions like
flurry rushing and perfect guarding
bullet time and using the environment or
sheikah slay to your advantage
but in terms of actual one-to-one
swordplay not that
much has changed in fact in a lot of
ways it's actually watered down compared
to previous installments like twilight
princess but
i'm getting ahead of myself in this
video i want to take a closer look at
how the combat system of previous games
measure up to that of the latest
installment that being breathed the wild
and see what kind of improvements can be
made in the sequel
whether it being a return to form or
completely new additions
of course since we are dealing with
three dimensions here i will limit the
scope of this video to the 3d
installments in the series
since the 2d games have a very different
and more simplistic approach to combat
which suits those types of games
so let's get into it inside breath of
the wild 2.
wait damn it wrong channel let's start
at the beginning with ocarina of time
the first 3d installment which laid the
groundwork for all future titles to come
coming off of a link to the past
obviously this game had to completely
reinvent how combat was going to work as
opposed to a simple stab or swing link
was given numerous options to work with
horizontal swings vertical swings stabs
stabs while crouching and shielding
jump attacks spin attacks and even some
stuff that didn't necessarily add
anything significant but was still an
interesting addition
like being able to reverse your swinging
pattern by tilting the control stick in
the opposite direction of the first
swing
as has become tradition for the 3d
zeldas standard swings can be extended
to a three-part combo with the third
swing acting as the finisher and after
some cooldown it resets to the first
swing for each variation the finisher is
different
again this doesn't really change or
impact the combat in any way but it
makes the sword combat seem more varied
and complex than it really is
to complement all of this z targeting
made its debut as a way to focus your
attacks on a specific
enemy without losing track of its
position some attacks like the regular
stab
jump attack and reverse horizontal swing
cannot even be executed without it
z targeting also grants more defensive
options like walking while shielding
sidestepping and a backflip to dodge
specific attacks
i remember as a kid purposely drawing
out a fight to make it look like an
epic battle whenever someone was
watching me play some people seem to
agree with
sequelitis that z targeting was trash
and it created a disconnect between the
combat section and the exploration
section but i completely disagree on
that front
first of all in most cases you don't
have to target an enemy it just makes
the fights easier
in fact in some occasions it's better
not to see target because z targeting
while having your sword out takes away
the options to roll
instead replacing it with the jump
attack this elaborate combat system
especially for its time has influenced
many different games in the future to
come
including the zelda games following in
its footsteps majira's mask being
developed in only a year and on the
ocarina engine
understandably reused the exact same
system with the only difference being
that link now has different forms and
thus some attacks are aesthetically
different with punches and kicks being
added to the mix but the core system
remains largely the same
the wind waker saw the inclusion of
parry moves where you need to time a
press of the a button right before an
enemy attack to perform either
a helm splitter or a back slice although
i appreciate the inclusion
i'm not really the biggest fan of this
mechanic the reason being that this
parry system is limited to specific
enemy types and particularly the ones
that can only be beaten
using this technique in other words the
game decides for you whether or not you
can use it
it also makes some of the enemies like
dark nuts feel a little bit more
gimmicky as you simply wait for that big
flashy button accompanied with a loud
sound and immediately hit their weak
spots automatically
it also doesn't help that you don't have
any control over which type of parry
attack you use
the game simply chooses for you based on
what kind of attack the enemy is
performing
taking away any incentive or strategy
from the player and apparently nintendo
agreed with all of this since in
twilight princess this parry system was
done away with again
the helm splitter and backslides are
still a thing but in this case can be
triggered on command
the helm splitter after a shield bash
and the backslides upon landing after a
sidestep
and perhaps most famously for twilight
princess and a big fan favorite was the
addition of hidden skills
link's base moveset wasn't anything
special and almost identical to that of
ocarina of time
however this can be expanded upon by
learning various hidden skills from the
hero's shade
of which the aforementioned helm
splitter and backslides are also part of
with the exception of the ending blow
which you are forced to learn since
well it's used to kill ganondorf at the
end none of the other hidden skills are
mandatory to beat the game
this works really well as it can make
fighting certain enemies like again dark
nuts
easier to fight with the hidden skills
but not near impossible without them
and just as a side note twilight
princess has by far
the best underwater combat system in the
entire series
just throwing that out there another
thing to mention is the three-part combo
system from ocarina of time is once
again present in both the wind waker and
twilight princess
a nice little inclusion this time around
is that you can change between the
different swings mid
combo by tilting the control stick in
different directions between each attack
this can result in all kinds of
different swings and finisher
combinations
again this doesn't really impact the
outcome but it looks cool
and then we got skyward sword and it
sucked moving on alright i'm just
kidding
jokes aside though skyward swords combat
is one of the most controversial aspects
and the wii in general for that matter
some thoroughly enjoyed it while others
broke their tv sets
i fall somewhere in between on this
matter i can see why nintendo tried it
and for a game which made use of such an
experimental control scheme it performed
reasonably well
one big thumbs up i would give to
skyward sword is the fact that the
directions of your swings actually
matter this time around
something i was actually surprised
wasn't included earlier to some degree
in previous installments the direction
of your sword swing was pure aesthetics
and it didn't serve any other function
it had no impact on whether or not you
would land a hit or not
why the game gets a thumbs down however
is that it only works well with
certain types of enemies i think
nintendo was a little overzealous with
this mechanic
and implemented it for pretty much every
enemy in the game this turned a lot of
the combat in skyward sword into a slow
paced game of
guess the direction the enemy woke god
will he get it right folks let's see
oh that was a shocker if i've ever seen
one
[Music]
and even if you were seemingly swinging
in the right direction
some enemies like the mccobblens shift
their guard around so frequently and so
abruptly that in some cases you're
better off just swinging away in random
directions anyway
i think it would have been better if
this was reserved for only specific
fights
the novelty of swinging a sword in real
time was already enough to make it fun
if anything forcing this directional
swing mechanic on even the most basic
enemies takes away that enjoyment
the fights with girohim were fast paced
and exciting so it definitely wasn't a
complete failure
of course i cannot really use skyward
swords combat as an example for most
things related to breath the wild and
its sequel since it exists in its own
world
and given the controversy surrounding
the motion controls i highly doubt
nintendo is going back to this control
scheme anytime soon unless we maybe get
a zelda game in vr one day
as mentioned in the opening narrative
breath the wild's combat options overall
are
amazing when looking at the whole
picture but at the same time the actual
swordplay was heavily stripped down
which is quite ironic if you take into
account all the different weapons we're
allowed to use in this installment all
those different swing directions
finishers and options we talked about
earlier have been neglected and we are
now stuck with the same simple
three-swing combo for one-handed weapons
two
swings for two-handed ones and a
five-stab combo for spears and halberds
you can no longer influence the
direction or the finishing move which is
kind of boring if you ask me
i am of course aware that breath of wild
introduced many new things in the form
of the chica slate more emphasis on the
bow and generally using the environment
to your advantage
but let's be fair here outside of the
great plateau tutorial section and some
situational moments here and there to
clear out camps the only room to really
be effective in high-paced combat
scenarios was stasis plus
and maybe occasionally a bomb but good
luck trying to kill a lino with a
boulder or hit a lizzle foes with a
metal crate after it's already spotted
you besides we are primarily focusing on
sword combat here so here's what i would
change to the overall sword mechanics
for the sequel
first of all bring back the hidden
skills this is a no-brainer
having the option to expand your moveset
is always a good thing in my book
especially if it's handled like in
twilight princess and isn't mandatory if
it's not mandatory it won't get in the
way of the open nature of the game and
thus will not bother anyone who doesn't
feel like collecting everything
hidden skills are purely there to make
link more powerful and expand his
options but are not required to beat any
specific enemy
second expand the combos you can perform
with each weapon
i can't believe i'm making this
comparison but remember star fox
adventures aka the legend of fox
dinosaur planet where you could perform
all these flashy combinations and
finishers
sure the combat itself was quite
repetitive but
it was cool how you could make fox do
all kinds of different strings
ending with a jump attack a roundhouse
kick or spin his staff around like a
helicopter blade
say what you want about this game but
some of the moves you could perform were
pretty damn cool
and just like in the wind waker and
twilight princess you can alternate
directions on the control stick to
change the order of the combo
in breath of the wild all that stuff was
gone which is a pretty big step back if
you ask me
especially since this is the first game
in the series where we can use so many
different kinds of weapons
next make the enemy ai more varied in
combat scenarios
now i know what you're thinking the ai
was already pretty advanced for a zelda
game right especially the bokoblins and
moblins
in terms of their overall behavior yes
and the way they interacted with some of
the chica runes or the environment
definitely but in terms of actual
one-to-one duels
not so much it still boils down to
waiting
blocking and the occasional parry here
and there and just wailing on them like
there's no tomorrow there's also no way
to break an enemy's defense
other than bashing away at their shield
or waiting until they let their guard
down
this ties in with the hidden skills we
covered earlier in twilight princess and
skyward sword you could use the shield
bash to open an enemy up
and in the case of twilight princess use
the back slice or helm splitter to
circumvent the enemy's defense
in general i would love to see a more
unpredictable attack pattern where you
need to use different strategies to
outsmart an enemy which in the case of
breath of wild doesn't really happen
unless you're fighting a boss ultimately
one of the biggest reasons for a lack of
impressive sword duels is of course the
enemy variety
something that a lot of people seem to
agree with no dark nuts stalfos iron
knuckles
re-deads or any of the other classic
enemies can be found
which is a shame as fighting some of
these enemies was very entertaining
now this next one is a bit more of a
personal one so i'm curious to see how
many of you agree with me
be sure to let me know down in the
comments so here's my take
giving an enemy insane amounts of hp
isn't hard
it's tedious i am of course referring to
the color variations of each enemy and
in particular the silver
and if you're playing on hard mode the
golden types making a fight an
ordeal because it takes ages to chip
away at their health
creates the illusion of difficulty but
the fight itself
isn't actually challenging the same
strategy still apply
the only quote unquote challenge here is
not losing your focus and attention
because of the endless repetition of
doing the same thing
over and over it's a test of patience
more than it is a test of skill once
you've become good at the game and can
parry almost
any attack successfully trigger flurry
rushes and generally know the attack
pattern of each enemy you are left with
very little than spending a long
long time to take down an enemy hard
mode's idea of difficulty was to just
have enemies regenerate health
which i think is kind of a lazy solution
to up the difficulty this also clashes
heavily with the weapon durability
system
i've stated before in previous videos
that i don't really have a problem with
the durability
in fact i think it was kind of a nice
change of pace for the series and
incentivized exploration and testing out
different weapons
but burning through two-thirds of your
inventory or even more in the process of
bringing down a silver or golden lino is
a bit much if you ask me the reward
doesn't outweigh the sacrifice
either the durability of the weapons
needs to go up or even better
make the enemy type stronger by making
their behavior more unpredictable
expand their moveset with attacks which
the weaker variants don't use
it's fine if they have more hp but not
to this degree
that's just my opinion of course some
quick honorable mentions i would also
like to see
bring back some sort of roll mechanic
this doesn't have to replace the jump by
any means
but rolling has always been that little
extra option to shift your herd box and
dodge certain attacks
i especially miss this mechanic while
fighting certain enemies like stone
talus or a high knocks
it would be great to be able to roll
underneath them and attack them from
behind
and as we saw in the star fox example a
role could perhaps be
expanded with a hidden skill which
allows you to do a lunge attack right
after
additionally i would also love to see a
certain degree of aerial combat options
we've had a jump attack since ocarina of
time and breath the wild had this too
together with a sort of ground pound
type of move while paragliding but i'm
talking about
actual sword swings while jumping in the
air you know like we see link do in
super smash brothers
again i absolutely love the new
additions breath the wild brought in
when it comes to fighting enemies
but i do feel like nintendo stripped
away a little too much from the previous
titles when it comes to the flexibility
the sword has
having access to spears and all kinds of
other different weapons is great
however their use is quite limited aside
from the regular predetermined swings
throwing a weapon or a charge attack
link is a pretty agile and young dude so
he can get a bit more acrobatic with his
fighting style maybe he should take some
notes from monk moss koshia
for a 10 000 year old guy he's pretty
light on his feet
now it's hard to say exactly if nintendo
will make big changes to the combat
system in breath of the wild too
or if they will greatly expand the
amount of enemy types for that matter
the big question is of course what will
link's new magic hand abilities be used
for
as of right now besides speculation we
have no idea what the implications of
this new mechanic will be
nor do we even know if it will be used
in combat will it affect link's sword
wielding arm can we still use two-handed
weapons and can we use one-handed
weapons in conjunction with the green
arm
as of right now i don't want to get too
speculative about this mechanic in
today's video so for now all we can do
is wait until we actually see some
gameplay which i'm super hyped for
and i hope you are too and now it's time
to give you all an
update about my upcoming schedule
because the next few weeks are going to
be a bit different from the norm
starting this sunday i'll be leaving for
my annual hiking trip so i won't be
making any content
until august 8th however i'm planning to
record one small additional video
tomorrow if i can find a time
and i will schedule this video to go up
next weekend to fill in the gap
this video will not feature any high
quality editing or animations as i only
have one day to produce it
my big calamity video i decided to save
for after i come back
and finish it with a clear mindset since
as you can probably imagine i'm doing a
lot of preparation right now
this way i can also premiere the episode
properly august itself will be filled
with different kinds of projects a
couple of which will be collaborations
with other creators so i hope you look
forward to that i also have a couple of
new patreon supporters to announce so a
big warm welcome to william
morales lord gannon lauricia jarvis
jen joe and julia clemen thank you all
so much for joining
you guys rock with that said
i will see you all in roughly 2 weeks
and as always thank you for watching
this is dawn signing off and have a good
one